how difficult is it to return a pro
tennis serve we invited the hardest
tennis server in finland to join us and
challenge strangers to return our serves
ah here we go if they managed to
complete all the levels they won 1 000
euros thanks to skillshare for
sponsoring this video first level myself
[Music]
85 kilometers an hour pretty good i mean
next we have to break the hundred are
you going to go all the way of course
hi
thanks thank you what's your tennis
background well top 10 information oh
okay i go all in he's one of the best
trevor in finland so i mean it will be a
nice challenge for me
never felt that much pressure with such
a bad serve sorry and by the way almost
80 of you guys watching haven't
subscribed so if you enjoy our content
make sure to subscribe and help us out
he's under pressure so he will have
pleasure not me
let's check it
[Music]
sorry boris it was a good try
so artwork are you ready just woke up
and
are you going to go all the way oh yeah
of course i'm here for the 1000 euros of
course
[Music]
that's in ready
[Music]
wasn't even close it's been really has a
difference still waiting it's going to
be a boring day i guess can i make the
first sir be gentle
unfortunately i sprained my ankle i can
do a serve i think
76. without the ankle brace it would
have been that we're being 176 here
i'm going all the way
oh no
it's getting cold i mean it's been half
an hour do you think you'll make it to
the final level i don't know i'm pretty
nervous so for level one you get to
choose whoever of us serves to you let's
say you you can survive okay thank you
thank you
that was a wrong decision i'm just
buffing all the time oh she's getting
ready to return to serve like a pro
oh that was a good side spin under spin
but she got it too slow maybe
yeah he's a pro do you wanna take the
main challenge i'm gonna take them in
challenge okay that's good that's good
well wait for the final level let's talk
about skillshare who was kind to sponsor
and make this video possible skillshare
is a creative learning platform with
thousands of online classes in a wide
range of topics such as film and video
illustration photography and
productivity if you have a specific
skill that you're trying to learn
skillshare is a great place to get
started recently i took the skillshare
class learn adobe after effects for
beginners by jordan wanda put with the
idea to learn make some cool special
effects one thousand euros on the line
it's all about luck now i go big one
i honestly didn't even see that it was
in because it was so fast with the hell
of the skillshare class i was able to
make this pretty cool edit in just a few
hours the classes are a great way to get
inspired to learn new skills
as a special offer the first 1 000 of
our viewers that sign up using our link
in the description will get a one month
free trial of skillshare so you can
start exploring your creativity today
thank you skillshare
unless somebody receives auto surf he
gets one thousand euros so make sure to
watch until the end we have our next
challenges real professionals see the
guy who is going to see so he's going to
say okay no problem no problem
many times on television
i think i just tried to block
ah nice
so
333 euros i've earned i see clever
[Music]
nice
that's the way to do it otto let's bring
it on he looks like a like a tourist and
a beginner one thousand euro prize all
right what are you gonna do with it my
wife is going to take care of that i
don't have to decide ready
i didn't see that you serve you didn't
serve
197 kilometers per hour oh i should have
got that so what would you do if you
receive otto serve i i have to buy new
tennis shoes
if he gets it you should buy more of
those american stocks yeah
[Music]
and he got it
time to change the outfit what's your
tennis background in playing my whole
life okay okay he's not fooling around
anymore
time to change the outfit again he's got
a shirt that says tennis on it
was it in
yeah it another very good she's excited
she's already going i think you're
standing a bit too far my serves are
going to be quite soft if i get it on
court that's another small victory for
me
oh
thank you 86 kilometers per hour
congrats for the first serve thank you
this is a great achievement
so we're going to switch up otto's lefty
serve is going to be level one i feel a
bit humiliated by okay but you can
humiliate him no but that's a given you
know he can he can use his stronger hand
too this is looking impressive
i have to write down these moves
[Music]
and he's gonna get it oh
i need to warm up again
i'm gonna swirl with the left hand also
okay
oh that was in that was in dessert
appreciate it
trying to get into my head but i'm going
to ace him you see he's nervous he's
nervous
oh
it wasn't an ace this time no it wasn't
an ace it's still a really good surf do
you have a tennis ball background i
played a little bit i'm more of a geek
i'm shaking
oh very easy nice
oh yeah that's it that's it that's it
that's it what would you do with 1 000
euros what would you spend it on my
hospital bill after after i tried to
receive these strokes but what if i fake
it i'm sure he won't see that coming
we got it wrong this time
if we fail it's because of the mic
that's that's a good excuse
oh nice return whoa
i'm gonna go to the end he doesn't play
who fierce yep
okay did i even have a chance
probably not oh we have our next
challenger marching with confidence i've
never tried to return an atp level here
so no i have a chat it's going to be
pretty hard for you or not
what's it in oh yeah yeah clearly in my
opinion 140. that's a great serve best
serve of my whole life i'm actually
sorry about this
i want to hear the confidence 140 i mean
the server was pretty fast professional
players they serve second service like
that
[Music]
[Music]
she tried the double bass technique
why did i know the tennis dog
oh she got it
fine is celebrating too
[Music]
oh
if you catch it you get 10 dog biscuits
what will you do with the 1 000 euros i
need to buy a six month dating present
for my girlfriend and also my little
sister's um graduation is coming up so i
need to get something so let's make this
i really hope you get it yeah here we go
[Music]
he got it on that's a clean one did you
feel any pressure there yes hundred
percent
oh
i need to guess backhander forehand and
then i have to go with my gut yeah last
challenger of the day
the final dance oh here we go otto take
it easy i'll buy you a coffee if i can
make it
yeah it was good zero chance this time
the winner is otto virtanen
congrats congrats one thousand euros
nice
thanks for skillshare for sponsoring
this video and making it possible until
next time